you ready to probably die bunch yeah
okay yeah okay all right okay I'm just
going through the control tutorial see
just right click - spinning spinning
left dude Dewey Dewey we got it all
right okay so I'm in uh the first bomb
do I just go have the first bomb yeah we
just started beginning okay
everybody has to start somewhere let's
just hope it doesn't end here to make
sure your experts have the manual and
are ready to help that's me all right
here we go
this screen is for your eyes only you
are not allowed to look at the bomb
defusal manual okay I would be pretty
hard for us to accomplish in this
current distance alright let's do this
so does this start as soon as I think Oh
started okay yeah it starts it starts
okay so what do you see I know the
general gist of it we've got wires we've
got funky signal symbols and we've got a
big blue button okay let's see wires
first wires okay what's up how many are
there alright there's six wires Oh Lord
okay are there any yellow wires there
are three yellow wires in the two three
and five position are there red wires
one red wire fourth position cut the
fourth wire and I believe you start at
the top and counting down cool all right
green we're good
we've got three symbols or weird funky
symbols symbols yeah yeah yeah okay what
is the top left symbol Oh with the penis
what is the bottom left symbol it is a
lambda with a cross through the top top
right symbol it's an H that's on acid
it's real curvy and no I totally got you
yeah and then what's the last one it's a
backwards C with a butthole okay so
you're gonna push the buttons in this
order uh-huh with the penis penis lambda
lambda psychedelic H H backwards C got
it green all right we got big blue
button alright big button where's the
button say it says press how many
batteries are there around the Bob there
will be some modules that have like
double a's in them there's two doublea's
one d battery
that's it is there a Linda cater next to
a label that says frk on it
No okay now press and hold the button
keep holding it and dough and what tell
me what color the strip is next to it
okay
red release the button when the timer
has a one in any of the positions okay
it's gonna be a spell green good we did
it yeah that's funny for the record I've
seen other people play this so that's
why I have a general indication of what
to say about things but that's my first
bomb I did I did it do you want to
switch off every bomber every few bombs
you could do a couple because I'm gonna
start not in the beginning so right
we're gonna have a little bit more
complicated stuff when I'm when I'm
defusing okay oh that's not that smart
or not yeah maybe I'll start okay all
ease into it alright do I keep with the
same bombs or do I go free play oh god
just keep like doing the progression of
bombs because it sort of adds concepts
and it sort of teaches you the game
alright something old something new
that's the next one alright let's go
we've got a bomb where do you want to
know the MU is it better to me to tell
you what modules are on here just pick a
module then we could start there it
doesn't really matter all right we got
funky symbols again just tell me what
four symbols you have alright we've got
that backwards paragraph symbol the
backwards P we've got an upside-down
exclamation mark we've got a six that
got squashed on the top of it and then
we've got like there's a triangle headed
squid with a T coming out the sahte left
side of it and it's squid with that
sideways T coming out the left side okay
yeah yeah okay so you're gonna press
them in this order squishy six squishy
six paragraph paragraph squid boy
squiddy boy question mark bingo we got
it okay we've got there's there's two
green circles in it there's a grid of
like 6x6 in a red triangle oh yeah yeah
yeah what is that one called it's like
the maze one here we go
okay it's subject we may just find the
maze with the matching circular markings
okay so the top leftmost circle you have
two circles right yeah would tell me
where your top leftmost circle or
leftmost like in the left half it may
not be on the second column fourth row
column for throat okay so that means
that you have another another circle
that's four spaces to the right and two
spaces up from that spot yes
fifth column second row yes okay cool
cool so which one is the white light in
third column first row so now you're
just gonna navigate the white light
where do I have to get it to the red
triangle where's the red triangle it is
a third column fourth row oh that's a
long one okay ready yeah we're gonna go
left left down down left left down two
down two to the right now you should be
in the circle yes and then up one up
right right up up right right we're like
halfway there right right down into the
other circle down right right down down
left two left two down one done one and
left one and that should be it right yep
that's it bingo Bongo all right we got
wires wires there we go how many six
wires six wires are there any yellow
wires no yellow what is the last digit
of the serial number serial it'll be on
the side it's a little peg it's a two no
yellow wires no but if are there any red
wires one red fifth position okay cut
the fourth wire again gotcha all right
[Laughter]
this is the hole Bob yeah that was it
yeah oh okay I thought you were just
like bad
[Laughter]
no no that's it yeah we did great has
great man Thank You Lynette how much
time do we have probably a couple
minutes done there was 132 should keep
going with me yeah let's do one more six
module yes we got this all right you
know it baby you know it we got wires
how many four how many red wires are
there one red first position is there
one blue wire
yes exactly one blue wire cut the first
wire okay green we're good all right we
got symbols tell me what you got we got
funky h backwards c with butthole we've
got a Z that's turned and curly on the
ends or an N that's curly on the ends a
backwards n that's curly on the ends
okay with a T in it a with Venus a with
dick mm-hmm squiggle in squiggle and
squiggle eh got it and backwards C got
it alright we've got more symbols we've
got what you got we've got a railroad
track or like a cross with another cross
like if you put two crosses you bring
them together at the bottom of it two
plus signs two plus signs got you got
you got you we got a e like in
encyclopedia yep yep we've got
candelabra a you with an eye we've got
Omega alright you're gonna push them in
this order railroad tracks mm-hmm heyy
mm-hmm you with an eye in at candelabra
and then Omega okay we're good green on
that one all right yes six more three
more to go we got a button white says
hold
is there a label anywhere on the bomb
with the CA r on it
no it says NSA is so there's no label
next to a little it a light that says
frk even though no frk just NSA what
color was the button the buttons white
press and hold the button tell me what
color the the light is it's blue release
the button when there's a four in any
position on the timer
Roger yay all right we got we got wires
5 of them 5 wires is the last wire black
it's white how many red wires are there
zero are there any black wires at all
one third position cut the first wire
okay we're good one more button more
button all right it's yellow yellow says
abort press and hold it and tell me the
color we got blue so release when
there's a four in any position on the
timer okay we're done yeah this is easy
easy I'm so good at this why do you
sound so sad and or uncertain about that
proud of Who I am as a person okay I
want a hard one
wait okay I can already go to Section
three Oh God okay how about just this
one this is one giant leap all right
hang on I I pulled the game up so I got
a uh-oh do you want to switch out we can
switch out we go three and three like
every three yeah we could do that yeah
okay
yeah well switch em we'll jump up to the
hard ones for you next time
all right cool so I'm just gonna keep I
actually I'm gonna switch to the manual
boom okay guy I'm ready ooh
I'm not gonna let you down I either
leave I don't even know where things are
so just you're gonna have to burn a
little easy and we'll give you a chance
learn how the thing works I don't have
my safe game on this actually so we have
to do what I have to do the easy ones
apparently it's okay it's okay you can
learn all right I'm ready I have gotten
rebound wires you are oh we're starting
now
oh we're in okay boys and it's happening
all right how many wires six all right
are there any yellow wires no what's the
last digit of the serial number ah
serial number ends with a nine is nine
odd or even not it is odd
okay cut the third wire green all right
we've got a button okay button yes it is
a blue button that says hold oh okay
hold it what color red strip hit release
when there's a one in any position Green
next once we got his symbols okay this
is perfect it just goes one after
another all right what do we got I
didn't do that on purpose at all I have
V Omega I have the squished six I have
the candelabra and I have the the train
tracks thingy okay signs do six train
tracks candelabra Omega all done do we
do it yeah bomb bomb defuse saved I
didn't die either that's pretty good
right that does that did actually
improve my personal best time by like 20
seconds you sound you sound surprised
[Laughter]
my dad is saying you totally set that up
for me but they may have accessed the
modules in the order they appear and may
known the answer to two of them before
you said anything but it's fine it's
fine it's fine you memorized the manual
Wow wires the wires in that and the
symbols you do so much that it's kind of
easy to remember what shortcuts you have
in the instructions good we're gonna do
double your money I'm in the top 17% in
the world on double your money already
so how I am so ready I make the mark
learn chat I'm learning really wires
first how many six sir all right a
yellow no yellows no yellows you know
what's the last of the serial number uh
it ends in a 5
ok that's odd definitely odd cut the
third wire green on that one all right
all right we have a symbols okay lay it
on done the next wires but I did it
wrong
backwards and with the squiggly ends all
right got it backwards see with the
butthole uh-huh
Oh with a dick with a dick and the
lambda with the with the little cross on
the top part go Oh dick lambda n
squiggles see butthole all right we got
another symbols one of syringe I've got
a candelabra yep backwards paragraph
forward-facing see with the butthole and
a black star
okay go candelabra see bud whole
paragraph star I back two wires we got
another wires six wires six wires
yellows two yellows two are there are
there red wires no red wires cut the
last wire we're green on that one last
thing we have is two buttons two buttons
are I'm ready the first one is a white
button that says upward okay is there a
label that says car
no okay
Preston see what color it is red okay
would look for a one position shut up
music I have to wait it's not fair for
you to be all traumatic when I have to
wait okay next button alright it's red
and it says detonate that's not a good
button okay is there more than one
battery on the bomb there are two
batteries on the bomb okay press and
immediately release it's a trick it's
all a trick it's fine all right cool oh
great there's there's a lot more modules
in this man yet do you want to see some
terrified [ __ ]
scroll down to like Morse code yeah
that's that's the correct response give
me a hard one give you a hard one all
right let's do pick up the pace shall we
I like it I'm only in the top 97% on
this one oh I solved this one with 2.9
seconds on the clock I think it's gonna
be fine I think it's gonna be fine also
also fine definitely all we got three
minutes on the timer
we started what's going it's going
cymbals oh [ __ ]
all right what do we got okay Omega with
six candelabra and a and with like a hat
and a thing on it's right foot got it go
six six candelabra and Omega done all
right the next two we haven't done yet I
have one that's got six buttons and at
the top there's a word and each button
has a word on it I don't even know what
this one's called okay I think I know
what you're talking about
it's like a black display and then six
buttons with like rectangles beneath it
ready the display says red red got it
okay
push the
the second column middle alright one
green light the display now says first
on it okay
why isn't this in alphabetical order
alright first top right all right
checkmark the display now says blank on
it okay second column middle done
alright the next one is a another
display with a number in it and then
beneath it is four buttons that are like
vertical rectangles oh okay
is the black button bigger and their
numbers right yeah they're numbers the
display is bigger and then the numbers
there's four guns by side together
there's a correct button what does the
number in the big say it's a one okay
press the button in the second position
now it is a 2 press the button in the
same position as before so second
position now it is a a four press the
button labeled four and now it is a four
press the button in the second no wait
what what what position did we press the
first time a second position okay second
position yeah check mark all right the
last this last one it says 1 ok press
2nd position again done ok twenty-six
point three seconds left on the timer I
actually read that wrong but I think
it's ok my camera died now the camera
alright we gotta do this completely
[Applause]
alright 26 seconds left we did the
second good thing totally wrong I just
got lucky on every answer I think so
yeah my chat says I'm the funniest one
don't tell marker whoops what no I mean
nothing it's fine I think I heard
something about that I could do this one
called no room for error that sounds
like something we'd be good at yeah one
mistake and it's all over wipe the sweat
off your palms and try not to let it get
to you
oh so we only get one one goof well we
haven't goofy so far usually
three goofs well I trust you was gonna
be great do it I know we can do it I
don't like to see you thinking that I
can do it I'd like you to know I know
you can do it I think you can do it
because I know you can do it all right
okay so from my lessons I learned we're
gonna go with wires first okay we got
six wires are there any yellows know
yellows what is the last digit of the
serial number zero
are there any red wires two red wires
okay cut the fourth wire fourth wire
green we're good okay there's one more
wire uh-oh if I could turn around there
we go it is three wires three wires are
there any red wires one red is the last
wire white no it's blue how many blue
wires are there one all right cut the
last wire okay we're good we got button
what do what do you got yellow or white
withold
is there a little light next to a label
that's as ciear on it
yes press and hold and tell me the color
it is white or at least when there's a
one in any position you got it confirmed
we're good go yeah all right we've got
the the the words with the six word
buttons got you what's it say
yes left column middle button okay
kaboom didn't do it right is that the
one that we did wrong last I think it
was you didn't do the second step last
time the instructions say look at the
label of the button that's marked in
step one
yeah and they use that a go to step two
and push the first button that appears
in the corresponding list so we're just
really close well just randomly kick
clicked and got three of them correct in
a row
alright man it's ridiculous Assam is
like simpler than that we cheated death
alright let's do it again I understand
and I will read the directions more
closely this time so ready it's good
we're good
we've got wires again I think there's
six of them are there any yellow wires
one yellow how many white wires are
there one are there any red wires one
red cut the fourth wire confirmed all
right we've got symbols hell yeah
tell me tell me tell me got paragraph
upside down question mark we've got a
smiley face with its tongue sticking out
we've got a a B with it T you're gonna
go paragraph is EB question mark smiley
face got it confirmed kill confirmed
we've got wires again how many four how
many red wires are there zero is the
last wire yellow know is how many blue
wires are there zero how many yellow
wires are there to cut the last wire
okay confirmed all right all right we
got the wordy thing again no Jam that
trial [ __ ] this one up real bad big what
is it says you are you are the letters
or the words the words you why you Airy
what does the rot what is the button
right button say on it bottom right says
you're with no apostrophe you're with no
apostrophe I'm gonna read words when I
read one that you see click it okay the
first one is uh-huh
next one is you space are the power went
out the power went out
uh-huh there is an aha God we're good
okay we got that okay it's dark that it
says yes now what is the middle left
button say no no you have to tell me
click the first one you see blank nope
ah with three H's nope wait yes okay the
next word is they're spelled th e ir
it's the middle right button say middle
right aha uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
all right click what you see uh-huh HOH
okay that's it
so okay we're good we're clear okay
we've got big number for small number
gotcha gotcha gotcha
what does the display say one press the
button in the second position okay gonna
tell me the display I hit the snooze
okay it's oh yeah sorry it's a to press
the button in the second position
okay the new number is a three press the
button in the third position okay new
number is a one trust the button in the
second position okay new number is a
three what number did you press in the
last stage in the last one yeah what
number not what position what number was
on the button that's a great question I
think it was a four I think you should
click before then I don't need to write
this [ __ ] down I can remember things
okay I forgot to ask what number you're
supposed to write things down should I
get a notepad right that that was not
luck I remembered what it was my memory
isn't that bad I remember all my regrets
yeah he thought it was a four and it was
so he thought correct
he doesn't say I don't know for maybe
[Laughter]
four terribly thanks man thanks for
getting my back I really appreciate that
thank you for the one who's gonna
explode anyway so I'm not that worried
about this all right this one's called
fair game no more hand-holding remember
everything you've learned because
anything can appear on this bomb alright
let's do this we've got oh my god what
is that there's no wires there's no
waters okay what do you wanna do first
I'd pick okay there are there's
something that looks like wires but it's
three and there's numbers on the left
side and letters on the right side it
looks like a shoelace their sequences
wire sequences okay
there are several panels with wires on
them but only the one panel is visible
at a time switch to the next panel by
using the Deaf button and the previous
panel by using the up button do not
switch to the next panel and it was the
right answer
oh did it checkmark yeah Oh God okay
wait but we need to know which oh [ __ ]
do you remember what color wires there
were red yeah they're red they were
already they're all red
okay what color worse do you have right
now is blue connected to B yeah cut the
blue wire that's connected to B to or
connected to be cut both of them no way
when we cut one cup one cup one cut one
sorry sorry one just one doesn't matter
just one you got it and then is there a
wire connected to a or C not a yes see
cut the one connected to C got it and I
think we can go to the next panel go
down whatever direction you went last
time
it says wrong now did it go back to like
the top no it just stayed here [ __ ]
maybe cut the other one connected to B I
guess you got it it love that it really
like that okay we're looking at a blue
and a black okay is the blue connected
to beat no okay cut the black got it
enough for the only two wires yes
okay next panel we're good okay we got a
black and a red is the black connected
to a or C a cut that one got it and is
the red connected to a or C a cut that
one okay and we're done with that pan
okay we're good okay yay we we've got
much time we've got two minute Oh
oh it amazed amazed amazed amazed
bobaloo tada
you're fine you're fine all right where
are the circles where's your furthest
left circle fourth columns sixth row
fourth column sixth row is your furthest
left yes so your next one is fifth
column third row yes okay so where is
your white dot fourth column fifth row
and where is your red concentrate chart
row okay so we're gonna go up up left 2
left 2 up 1
ok we're there we're good alright ok ok
we've got Simon Says oh yeah I suck at
this one yellow oh god everything went
red don't don't push me think don't push
me think no I mean everything in the
room is red okay no strikes
right foot push push green dream I mean
the yellow ones lighting up did I say
that yeah yellow flash yep no it didn't
like green it didn't like it didn't like
green it did not like green Bob I'm
gonna die I think you might die oh wait
I'm sorry
we must be on the wrong one okay we have
one strike yellow fashion it still says
green know what you did talk to you from
the grave now oh we already had strikes
oh [ __ ] that was overall strikes not
strikes of the game damn it I forgot how
that role worked
still still think this game is awesome
yeah it's awesome yeah okay all right
well your turn I guess I tried three
times that's fair
fair's fair fair is fair I'm gonna guide
you to victory and I'm definitely not
going to try to get you killed because
you obviously sabotage me all right well
since fair's fair we're gonna do fair
game
all right the same one right oh wait
that's where we did that already hang
out no we'll do a different well that
was good because it was just a whole
bunch of [ __ ] I didn't know all right
let's do it
okay here you ready
I'm this is gonna it's fun it's good
I have wires but they have stars on them
they're they're complicated wires
well stars the bottom row has boxes and
some of them have stars they're not
regular wires they're complex wires all
right well that's not on my that's all I
found it okay all right
for each wire use the Venn diagram below
to decide whether or not to get the fire
at what the first one is white with no
star okay white you said correct yeah
why yeah no star yeah is the led on
no cut it okay we're fine next one is no
LED blue no star okay blue no star
what's the last digit of the serial
number nine
don't cut it okay the next one is blue
and white with an LED but no star okay
blue and white LED blue and white LED no
star wait oh I may have done something
wrong have a parallel port does the Bob
have oh jeez it has to to was a parallel
port like a DVI port no a parallel port
let me look at the thing a parallel port
is it it's like a DVI but it has two
rows long very low ports no parallel
okay don't cut it okay the next one is
white with no LED at no star okay no LED
no stars are the same as the first white
one go ahead and cut that one okay we're
done we have a button we can do buttons
all right what's it say it's white it
says press are there any batteries new
batteries okay two batteries okay press
and tell me what color yellow
all right look for a five crap it has to
go all the way around now okay I don't
want to stress you out but we have a
minute and 36 seconds left plenty of
time we have simon says we could
probably do this alright what's the
colour it's flashing blue flashing blue
serial number ends in a nine and we have
no strikes
okay go yellow wrong now we have one
strike what is that but it said oh does
it contain a vowel oh uh yes okay go
green got it now it's giving me two
blues screaming green green yeah it gave
me three blues so green green green
green time okay now we have to do Morse
code in 30 seconds oh hi the Morse code
one I've got
I got it I got it okay short long short
short short long short short short long
short short that's about what to
repeated letters it's I mean there's L I
mean it's either three seconds per game
they just throw these modules you've
never seen before
got you gotta be smarter than the PDF
I'm not I'm not smarter man all right we
got this one we got this one okay oh
yeah all right now that I'm learned
about the ones that we didn't get will
be so fast watch this is gonna be so
fast all right all right we got a
regular wires regular love it love it I
don't know 104 wires all right is there
a red wire to Red's okay
what's the last digit of the serial
number it is a zero okay are there any
yellow wires oh wait no one silo
are there any blue wires no blues there
was one yellow yes okay cut the second
wire we're good
all right now we have complicated wires
all right I'm ready I did this one we're
good
okay what's the first one red and white
with no LED and a star what does it have
a parallel port that's the two long one
yes it does
cut it good all right what's next one is
blue and white with an LED and a star
blue LED blue LED and white blue and
white okay blue white LED and a star is
there there is a parallel port cut it
okay all right the next one is red with
no LED and a star right that's loud no
LED and a star yeah
cut it the next one is blue and white
with no LED and a star
don't cut okay the next one is blue and
red
no LED and no star blue and red
yeah no LED and a star cut it and the
last one I have to cut because it's not
done okay we're done
next I have number big number display
with buttons okay big number four
buttons what is it one okay press the
second position I'm gonna I'm busting
out notepad for this because okay I want
to make sure you don't die now I have a
four so one a four same position which
was second position yep
I pressed a three that around okay and
now it says a four okay press the button
labeled four that's in the first
position and now I have a two okay
press the st. the button in the first
position alright that's a two in the
first position and now it says three
okay press the button with the same
label you press in stage four which was
a - yep done yeah yeah yeah now we have
Simon Says alright was the flashing oh
wait is does the serial number lol no
vowels no strikes and it's flashing
green all right hit green yep
that gave me green red green red green
blue yep and now it gave me green red
blue green blue yellow and now it gave
me green red blue red green blue yellow
blue done alright the last one is a
display with five letters showing on it
and it has an arrow above and below each
letter to cycle it so we can we have to
like spell a five letter word got it
okay the buttons above and below each
letter will cycle through the
possibilities only one combination of
letters available will match the
password below press the submit button
when the correct one has been okay so
the options for the first letter R u u y
Y Z s D and M
okay it's s okay what what are my
options for s just small sound spell
still study small sound spell still
study yeah you're looking for M opt and
M opt I have a Pete I'm gonna go for
spill yeah it's better spell spell yeah
Oh 21 seconds left oh my god Oh no prob
holy [ __ ]
totally killed it two percent that's not
for good and to win has finished this
with a minute and 11 seconds left on the
flow [ __ ] okay we're gonna do we're
gonna do eight minutes that's a lot of
minutes eight minutes
Oh eight modules Oh God that's good
though because take your time relax it
says okay fine thanks game thanks Vinnie
video game for your encouragement oh my
god
[ __ ] have you started pay we have a
button let's do the button that's
relaxing alright but it's red and it
says hold okay if it's red
it says hold press and release ha ha all
right let's do there's one that's got
three wires and on the left it says one
two three and on the high that says ABC
shoelace okay all right okay
what do you see a by a one black and two
blues okay is the red connected to see
black and to just go ahead and cut that
black one I don't even care what it's do
then there's the first blue is connected
to a huh the second blue is connected to
C all right what does it mean by
occurrence so the from the top down
there one two and three so the first
blue is the highest blue I have on here
ah just you have to keep track of how
many we've seen as we go through the
panels you said the second one was
connected to what C cut the second one
and we're done yeah okay that's good
I have another another blue that's our
third blue which is connected to a don't
cut shred is connected to B okay don't
cut that either all right now all right
the second red is connected to a don't
cut it third red is connected to C don't
cut it the fourth blue is connected to a
cut it dunzo all right
the fourth some of the red the next
thread is C the third or fourth it's the
four it's connected to a four thread
connected to a got it
fifth red connected to be cut it done
that's easier when you when you say it
like that it's super easy yeah we got to
do the words display with six words
under it one all right I'm ready
it says you are you space are you space
are okay what does it say in the bottom
right aha with the h-huh okay I'm gonna
read you words oh yeah huh son Oh
okay all right this display says the
letters you are right next to each other
you are top left no all right here we go
blank done okay it says they are they
are two separate words today space our
middle left o with three H's okay ready
nothing left undone done done it he done
done now we got a regular wires six
wires six wires all right any yellows
one yellow any White's
one white are there any Reds no Reds cut
the last wire tons oh we got symbols we
know symbols we can be similar no
symbols I like symbols I've got a
candelabra yep and Omega yep the
backwards e with eyeballs on top oh yeah
and a backwards H no an end thing with
big with a hat and a foot okay do that
II think yeah candelabra yep the N and
the Omega Danzo we got numbers big
number with four numbers under it all
right I'm ready
i'ma write down two okay to press the
second position which is a number three
okay it says 1 press the button labeled
four that's in the third position ok it
says 3 press the button in the third
position that's a number one mm-hmm it's
is for press the button in the same
position the same position you pressed
as in stage two which was I believe this
aim no it was the one labeled four which
was you said it was in the third
position yep okay that was a number one
I just pushed and the screen says one
okay same label you pressed in stage one
which was a three done all right we have
another two wires three wires a B and C
things situation one okay all right yeah
I'm ready
the first black wires going in to be cut
second black wires going into a cut
alright next panel third black wires
going into C don't cut first red wires
going into C cut okay the second red
wires going into B cut the first blue
wires going into a don't cut the second
blue wires going into B do not cut all
right
the black wire whatever number it is is
going into C third fourth cut and then
the red wire going into a cut and then a
black wire going in to be cut dunzo
alright save the best for last it's
Morse code time okay how much time we
get two minutes
okay I got long short short short long
short short short that's be short long
short short short long short short short
short short long oh I I get what you're
long short short short okay long short
short short short short long
it's beats it's 3.6 3.6 even 3.6 even
done
we did the whole thing
[Laughter]
[Music]